i always want to play wolverine
keanu is that real did you really want
to play wolverine
oh yeah frank miller's wolverine for
sure
how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe the x-men
in the marvel cinematic universe this is
something that the fans have been
waiting for for a very
long time and ever since the disney fox
acquisition where all of the marvel
characters including the x-men the
fantastic
four doctor doom galactus and many other
marvel characters went back to disney
fans have been waiting for an x-men
announcement and we sort of got that at
2019 san diego comic-con where kevin
feige mentioned
mutants and fans have been wondering
when but they've also been wondering
who who is going to play these new x-men
characters in the marvel cinematic
universe and by far the biggest fan cast
for
fans has been keanu reeves as wolverine
and
as it turns out keanu reeves has always
wanted to play wolverine
this would make fans go absolutely crazy
but keanu reeve shares his true
thoughts in this video real quick don't
forget to subscribe to stay up to date
on the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a deadpool versus cable funko pop
it's not too late it is too late not too
late for chiani to play wolverine i'm
just going to leave
that right there i'm all good with it
now
but that was i'm leaving that there
oh yeah frank miller's wolverine for
sure
yeah so as you just heard keanu reeves
actually has always wanted to play
wolverine specifically
frank miller's wolverine and this is
very interesting because frank miller
actually did the artwork for wolverine
volume
one the cover is actually quite famous
and is done by frank miller and this is
the version that keanu reeves has always
wanted to play
now as keanu reeves said he feels like
it's too late for him to play wolverine
and he's okay with that but alex winter
replied
it's not too late and that really is the
question is it too late for keanu reeves
to play wolverine in the mcu
marvel studios is president and now the
ceo over marvel and entirety
kevin feige has confirmed that they
actually talk to keanu reeves about
every
mcu project that they do this is much
like they did for jake
gyllenhaal they talked to him about
countless mcu projects until they came
across the role mysterio he passed on a
lot of projects and a lot of character
roles until they decided that mysteria
was the role for him and boy were they
right
and the same thing is happening with
keanu reeves marvel consults with him
about every project
looking for a character that he can play
in the mcu marvel studios does this with
a lot of celebrities just take the
eternals for example they have angelina
jolie salma hayek and a star-studded
cast so it seems like it's only a matter
of time until kianu enters the mcu but
it doesn't look like he's going to be
playing wolverine he thinks that it's
too late now and unfortunately he's
probably right
since the x-men are going to be rebooted
in the mcu marvel studios probably wants
a younger wolverine but the multiverse
now exists in the mcu so who's to say
that he couldn't show up and play an
alternate reality version of wolverine
one that's older and doesn't require a
commitment of 10 to 15 years
that's something that we can absolutely
hope for but as of right now it doesn't
seem like keanu reeves is going to be
taking the mantle of wolverine
it's certainly sad news but who else
would you like to see keanu reeves play
in the mcu
what role would be perfect for him let
me know what role you think would be
good in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof